mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs j'ai
le bonheur leur avantage l'extrême
difficulté d extirper propos s'est
extirpé profond maintenant qu'elle qui
sont cohérents de 700 francs vous ne
pouvez pas arrêter tout le monde en même
temps à les extirper quelques sont
cohérentes cet instrument appelé des
actes mandat au sein du trombone à
coulisse un quelques modèles prévus et
corrigé va masseglia pas alors je
rappelle pour vous très très
succinctement les principes de
fonctionnement c'est nous
mais comme boucher
remporté une bataille d'hommes dans le
bosch dans le boys band
sera pas pour vous très brièvement les
principes de fonctionnement qui était
une de nombreuses pressions
demain matin
c'est une des nombreuses principle
inventé par archimède savez qui est
archi m archimède est déçu célèbre
coureur à pied qui gagna les marathons
âge aux logiques de salamine insu mais
tu avais l'habitude de se décontracter
en prenant des bains et le respect des
poussées cela lui donnait des idées va
il consignait sous forme de poème
allemand intitulé et principes dont les
plus connues et les suivantes focus
thoracique en keystone yves villers zone
wirwignes euros le vide m6 des verts
dans les traductions et approximatifs et
les suivants tout corps plongé dans
l'eau froide qui n'est pas réapparu au
bout d'un quart d'heure peut être
considérée comme perdue
moi
les cadets je vous remercie de ce n'est
pas de moi
cette race humaine alors je rappelle les
principes de fonctionnement qui est le
suivant il suffit d envoyer de l'air
chaud de ses côtés il est l'autre côté
vous triez voilà je vais donner tout de
suite vos d'échantillons mais miley bofa
a confirmé
je suis un peu bas je suis un peu par
cet instrument
s'il est bon que vous passez votre
éducation musicale
enfin cet instrument à cordes un tyran
ou poussant sur la becque bas alors
maintenant normalement je devrais jouer
plus juste rats en réalité j'aurais
moins fort
d'après les principes de relativité de
einstein un camarade de h & m
l'américain jerome à chacun son nom
depuis la musique
cela tire une sonnette de ma mère de
l'expérience est importante
alors je vais quand même c'est fini
beaucoup
ouf
un bon coup de tonnerre vous promets moi
c'est mon seul souci on comprend d'où
cet appel pour être assidu aux
professionnels a fait 60 ans sur la
partition de gp
la fois lourd l'âge au diable les
familles et les visas aux membres ans
jean-sébastien saison fut dans son
ensemble ait alors greta la fille du
colonel
je suis dans les fonds propres
prévu
ne trouvez pas le soleil ou aux 82
millions de téléspectateurs
pour fédérer tous heures à la maison des
grands prix
ou au temps des murs contre 6,30 en
rouge de la tête
la veille un sommet dans lune de miel à
la vie des gens n'est pas
attar wakata getafe